Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
We just got a bunch of announcements
about what's going on in Superman Legacy,
who some of the villains are going to be.
There's a bunch of characters,
both heroes and villains, that James
Gunn announced himself earlier this year.
So we'll break it all down.
you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos,
starting with the biggest thing first.
This past week you probably saw
we learned Brainiac and Angela Spica the engineer
from the Wildstorm
Comics are going to be some of the antagonists
We already knew that
they were bringing the Wildstorm characters into DC,
like they're going to be doing an authority movie
after Superman Legacy.
So it makes sense that they'd introduce
some of those characters during Superman Legacy.
James could also push back on the idea
that the engineer would be a villain in the movie.
Like I wouldn't call her a villain.
So it sounds like she might just be a minor antagonist
to Superman for some of the movie.
but. Brainiac is supposed to be the actual main villain
now we've
learned that at least part of the authority team
will debut during Superman Legacy.
The engineer becomes part of that team in the comics,
But they didn't say which other members of the
authority will be in Superman legacy in whether or not
the engineer will actually be on the team.
At the beginning of the film, There might
just be a few members of the team in the movie.
Here's where we get to the actual plot of the film.
So when the events of the movie pick up
Superman is still very early in his career.
He is widely known around the world.
Yet then in the Middle East,
there's a conflict that serves as his big public debut,
where everything gets caught on
camera spread all over the world.
Everyone sees him and what he can do.
the movie's not going to be an origin story for him.
It'll be kind of like the Batman movie
with Robert Pattinson where it's Batman Year two.
So he's already been Batman for a little while,
but he's still sort of figuring out the Batman identity
just in general.
So it's the same situation for Superman.
Superman starts the movie already having a version
of the Fortress of Solitude In the fortress.
Alerts him to the presence
of this Kryptonian technology
that these terrorists have gotten their hands on.
he feels like the Kryptonian tech
will provide some clues about Krypton,
revealing that when the movie picks up,
he doesn't know that much
about his true origins or what happened to Krypton
just in general.
Generally, all the Kryptonian lore,
that's part of Superman's heritage in the comics,
in the previous movies,
they kind of did this during the Smallville series.
Like some of this will sound familiar, like, yeah, he
grows up not knowing about Krypton and gets his powers.
then he learns about Jor-El,
his true heritage, all that stuff
Separately.
When the movie picks up, General Sam Lane and Amanda
Waller learn the terrorists had the Kryptonian tech
on their side of things in the U.S.
government, they send the authority to investigate.
So that's how they get involved with Superman
while he's there to in it sounds like the way they're
positioning things like the authority do not trust
Superman at first because he's so powerful.
Nobody on the planet
really knows that much about him in the Kryptonian
technology is so advanced and powerful In both sides
want the technology itself.
So at least at the beginning of things.
It sounds like they started odds with each other.
this might be where
the engineer character gets involved.
I don't know if he's going to start the movie
being on the authority team, like I said, or join
the team later during the movie war,
join the team during the events of the separate spinoff
authority movie
that they're doing at some point after Superman Legacy.
but in the comics, the engineer is a woman who grew up
knowing the first version of the engineer.
She use his technology to replace her blood with
nanites, turning her body basically into liquid metal.
It gives her all kinds of abilities.
she can assimilate other technology. She can fly.
She can control other machines remotely.
She doesn't have normal human body parts.
So she can survive in the vacuum of space
or harsh environments.
She's super powerful
the way that James Gunn was pushing back
on the idea that she was like a villain
and could have like a traditional type of villain,
kind of like Brainiac made
it sound like she'll just start at odds with Superman.
early theory she might wind up assimilating
some Kryptonian technology
during the movie, giving her a big upgrade
and part of her DCU origin story.
some of you also probably realize that some of this
subplot in the movie with General Sam Lane, Amanda
Waller working together, the Kryptonian technology
that people on Earth
getting their hands on Superman
generally not knowing about Krypton itself,
all make Superman legacy also sound a little bit
like the plot of my Adventures
with Superman TV series is great series
if you haven't seen it yet, It's on HBO, Max.
but it's a totally different
take on Superman's origin story.
They invoke a lot of multiverse during that, too.
Funny enough, because we're in the middle of this
multiverse stuff that marvel during that series.
His Fortress of Solitude is an actual ship,
kind of like the way that Zack Snyder, during his
Justice League trilogy, had a Fortress of Solitude,
being an all Kryptonian ship.
but. Up to present day, this version of Superman's
been afraid to actually enter it.
So he hasn't learned that much about his origin story.
Like the ship itself, the eye of Jor-El hasn't
taught him that much about Krypton.
They also just ended season one, teasing
that Zod and Brainiac are coming to conquer Earth,
who are a little bit different,
that are previous incarnations,
in at least at some point in the past of this Earth,
Zod seems like he tried to invade Earth
with a Kryptonian army or other Kryptonians
tried to invade, which is now General Lane.
In the Mando Walter got their hands on
Kryptonian weaponry in the first place,
But all that stuff is totally separate
from Superman Legacy, Superman's BackStory.
General Lane, Amanda Waller. Zod.
Brainiac stories in the movie
We'll probably be just a little bit different.
We heard rumors about Brainiac
being in the movie earlier this year.
and because Superman starts the movie not really
knowing anything about Krypton, just in general,
they might use his encounter with Brainiac
to teach him about Krypton in his heritage.
Because when the movie picks out, Brainiac would have
already been to Krypton and stormed the bottle.
City of Candor before it had blown up.
so. Brainiac knows all about Kryptonians
and their history.
Also, they're working on the new Supergirl
Woman of Tomorrow movie Brainiac in the Bottle.
City of Candor.
Might help set her movie up a little bit too.
James Gunn hasn't really explained
what Superman's relationship with Supergirl
is like during this first Superman Legacy movie.
If he's met her, if she knows she exists,
if she knows he exists.
Merrily there is.
We'll get some kind of teaser for her during the movie,
like there's another Kryptonian out there somewhere.
But I don't think that she's in Superman legacy.
Like, the actual character isn't in the movie.
So it might just be some verbal teaser or information
or something that Brainiac says during the film.
the whole plot with Brainiac coming for Earth
and Superman meeting him for the first time
sounds a lot like the more recent Geoff Johns Brainiac
storyline, where basically that's what goes down.
The only difference in the comic book
storyline is that when Brainiac came from Earth,
Superman was much older
and he already knew all about his Kryptonian heritage.
but it sounds like when the movie picks up,
the authority is treating
Superman kind of as an antagonist,
not really trusting him
at first in over the course of the movie,
he helps them defeat Brainiac saving the planet.
So you can kind of see the plot like slowly.
He'll win their trust,
but it takes a little while for that to happen.
James Gunn did say that a big
theme of the movie would be Superman
trying to reconcile his Kryptonian heritage
in his life on Earth as Clark Kent,
because for the most part, like I said, he starts
the movie only knowing himself as Clark Kent.
Corn fed farm boy from Kansas and this also just
gets back to the whole Smallville series.
That's basically the way they did things
on the Smallville series with his backstory.
Like he grew up as Clark Kent,
then got his powers, then learned about Krypton,
the Fortress of Solitude, Dora, all that stuff,
But it took several seasons
for him to learn all those things, like he didn't
get the big info right at the beginning of season one.
there are a ton of other characters
they announced in the movie, like Nathan Fillion as Guy
Gardner, Green Lantern.
So it sounds like the Earth already
has many superheroes running around.
When Superman is born and grows up
like a lot of superheroes active on the planet.
was a gift from my.
The head of my makeup department over at Castle.
Her name is Debbie Zeller.
Thank you, Debbie. I'm looking to the reflection.
Thank you, Debbie, very much for my shirt.
I told you it would come in handy
and I think brings out the green under my eyes.
The next thing is a big premiere
HBO television series called Lantern.
This is a story of a couple of Green Lanterns,
Jon Stewart and Hal Jordan.
And we have a few other lanterns peppered in there.
But this is really a terrestrial based TV show,
which is almost like true detective
with a couple of green lanterns
who are space cops watching over precinct Earth.
In it, they discover a terrifying mystery
that ties into our larger story of the DCU.
we don't really know how a ton of these other super
heroes and villains get involved in the movie.
Like Lex Luthor, for example.
He's still a bit of a question mark.
He sounds like he's only going to be a minor antagonist
during this first film.
like he'll watch everything
with Superman versus Brainiac go down in.
Unlike all the regular people, he'll actually grow
to mistrust Superman, even more Like if you're
this powerful, you can defeat someone like Brainiac
that makes you even more dangerous than brainiac.
I've done a few other videos
about the rest of the cast.
We'll post links to that at the end of this video.
But separately, Jason Momoa also just confirmed
that he would be back at DC in
James Gunn's new DCU movies, but Aquaman two
would be his last time as the main character,
clearing up a little bit of the confusion.
it true this might be the last one
or could there be a third Aquaman?
I mean, it's things have happened before,
this is kind of like the end of this,
this DC, DC universe.
will always be a place for me.
A DC they were there. Will Right.
There's like,
like, yeah.
You know, we like you.
basically it looks like he's back as Lobo,
but I don't know if he'll debut in Superman Legacy.
There's already so many characters in that movie,
so it might not be till like Superman Woman of Tomorrow
or like some other DC movie
where they show him for the first time.
I've already done a much bigger Jason Momoa Lobo video,
so I'll post links for that down
the description below. the post.
All your reactions about Brainiac, the authority
characters, What's going on in Superman legacy.
If you have any big questions to I'll do more videos.
As we get more announcements about the movie.
They'll be filming relatively soon, so we'll start
getting some more actual footage of the film.
click here for my Loki Season
3 video and click here to learn about
Green Lantern in the rest of the big DC characters
in Superman Legacy.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!